if it's with the collector then it's not
safe only an idiot would give that
menace tome or genius how do you know
he's not going for one of the other
stones there's six stones out there
Thanos already has the power stone
because he stole it last week he
decimated Xander
he stole the space stone from me Nova a
character that many fans have been
waiting to see in the MCU for a very
long time the writers of Avengers
infinity war and Avengers in game have
revealed that Nova was originally going
to make his MCU debut in Avengers
infinity war in fact his introduction in
Avengers infinity war would have changed
the entire beginning of the film and it
would have impacted some events that
took place in both infinity war and
endgame in fact it was supposed to be
Nova Richard Ryder himself that was
supposed to take the place of the Silver
Surfer in Avengers infinity war his
character would then of course go on to
play a role in Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame but sadly of course as
we all know this did not end up
happening how's it going everybody it's
Warren and today we have some news
directly from the writers of Avengers
infinity war and Avengers and game
themselves about an alternate beginning
for Avengers infinity war that would
have changed infinity war and end game
and would have also introduced Nova and
like I said we previously learned that
Nova was going to be introduced in
Avengers infinity war but now we have a
lot more information about what exactly
was going to happen and of course right
now there have been reports stating that
Nova is actually going to be entering
the MCU soon so let's talk about what
this alternate beginning the original
beginning for Avengers infinity war it
was supposed to be quick reminder about
my xbox one and ps4 giveaway all you
have to do to enter for your chance to
win is be subscribed to my channel like
the video and leave a comment down below
so on Thursday comicbook.com had an
interview with christopher markus and
stephen mcfeely who of course are the
writers of Avengers infinity war and
avengers endgame and in this interview
the two writers revealed that Avengers
infinity war almost had a different
beginning one that involved the
introduction of Nova and one that would
introduce the send Arian world mine in
the interview they said we actually had
AI
remember in the big manifesto thing that
we did where the first work we did on
these movies where we just every
possible story line that you could take
from what's around the Nova has this and
Aryan world line yeah
the send Aryan world mine was that after
it was almost going in this conception
he would be The Herald not unlike the
halt who was actually standing in for
the Silver Surfer but that one member of
the Nova Corps survived Santos's attack
the send Aryan world mind would be the
voice of Glenn Close because you had her
and why not and that he would be Richard
Ryder and he would come to earth
Christopher Marcus says that it would
have been amazing but in the end they
decided not to introduce Nova into the
MCU this was because there was already
so much going on in Avengers infinity
war and Avengers in game and they were
already introducing new things stephen
mcfeely ended by saying but you're
introducing a whole new character when
we're trying to say goodbye to all the
ones that you know which is ultimately
why they decided to not introduce Nova
into the MCU in Avengers infinity war so
this would have changed the beginning of
Avengers infinity war and not only the
beginning of that movie but it would
have changed the events throughout
infinity war and endgame because now we
would have had a new character Nova so
he would have had to fit in somewhere
plus they were going to introduce the
zan darian world mine which is a whole
nother aspect on its own so what was
going to happen is that we were going to
actually see the destruction of
xand arm we were going to see every
single person of zan dart get destroyed
except for Richard Rider which would
have made him in hair at the Nova force
then we would have seen a scene with his
Andorian world mind which I will explain
in a second and then we would have seen
nova not the Hulk crash into dr.
Strange's sanctum sanctorum deliver the
message that Thanos is coming and then
have his character art play out through
both movies as well and going back to
the destruction of his and are not only
would we have seen that and Richard
Rider getting the Nova force but we
would have also seen this in darian
world mind
now this in darian world mind is a huge
sand Darian supercomputer now the data
of this supercomputer is entirely made
up of the experiences the histories and
the personalities of deceased members of
the Nova Corps along with the general
populace of Xand art as well the
computer has two jobs one is to
preserve itself and the other is to act
as a custodian to the Nova force which
of course Richard Reiter would have
inherited as he became Nova now in the
comics the world mind was deactivated
with the destruction of xander which is
probably what we would have seen in
Avengers infinity war since we would
have saws and Arkin destroyed and is
something that we will most likely see
when Nova is actually and finally
introduced into the MCU but this
information does tell us a lot in terms
of how Marvel is planning on introducing
Nova into the MCU and what his story arc
is going to be now we actually have a
lot of information in regards to Nova
being introduced into the MCU from a lot
of verified sources and from Kevin Feige
the president of Marvel Studios himself
Nova was originally supposed to be
introduced in the first guardians of the
galaxy film and will most likely be
introduced in the next guardians of the
galaxy film guardians of the galaxy vol
3 there have been talks that he will be
and he should be introduced in another
movie before getting his own movie this
makes sense because not too many people
outside of our fandom know who Nova is
he's not a huge character like Iron Man
Captain America or the Hulk that
everybody just kind of knows who they
are however of course our fandom does
know who he is and he is widely loved he
is a great character which is why Kevin
Feige has mentioned that Nova is on the
top of their priority list as far as
introducing him into the MCU goes and
Kevin Feige has still confirmed this to
be true after avengers endgame in a
previous interview with comic book calm
Kevin Feige said Nova is if we have a
big board with a bunch of characters
that have more immediate potential Nova
is on that board because of the
connection to the guardians universe
because there are more than one examples
to pull from in the comics that are
interesting and you're absolutely right
he was in the earliest drafts of
guardians of the galaxy so Kevin Feige
said this in a previous interview but
when he was asked after avengers endgame
if this was still true he said yes still
true
that's still true so we know that he's
going to enter the MCU soon and now it
seems like we sort of know how he's
going to be introduced we know that
after the end of Avengers endgame Thor
left with the guardians of the galaxy
however we know that this probably won't
last that long
Thor probably won't be in guardians of
the galaxy 3 that much if anything he's
just going to be in the very
beginning because we know that Thor love
and thunder comes before guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 Thor love and thunders
going to be in phase 4 and Guardians 3
hasn't even really been announced yet so
what will most likely see in the MCU
take place is that in Thor love and
thunder the guardians are most likely
going to drop Thor off somewhere we know
this because we actually know quite a
bit about for love and thunder we know
that Jane Foster Thor is going to be in
the movie and that she is going to wield
Mjolnir so the story is definitely not
going to focus primarily on Thor and the
guardians of the galaxy so the guardians
will drop off Thor and then they're
going to go do their own thing and we
know that they're most likely going to
search for Gamora but one of the first
things they're going to do is probably
go twos and are in Avengers infinity war
we learned and the guardians of the
galaxy learned from Thor that Thanos
decimated Xander now this is the scene
where Nova was supposed to be introduced
and we were actually supposed to see
this scene now obviously this scene did
not make it into the movie but you can
tell in this scene where Thor tells the
Guardians that Xander has been destroyed
you can tell how devastated star-lord
was finest already has the Power Stone
because he stole it last week he
decimated Xander so one of the first
things that the guardians are most
likely going to do is return to Xander
to see how much damage has been done
this is most likely where we're going to
see Nova get introduced to the MCU based
off of the story that the Marvel writers
have already wrote there is one
remaining survivor of the decimation of
Xander and if that one remaining
survivor is Nova Corps member Richard
Reiter the writers revealed this in an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter
when they said I remember going through
several scenarios of Nova Thanos could
come and kill all the Nova Corps except
one guy Richard Reiter
now since Richard Ryder is going to be
the only surviving member of the Nova
Corps since all of the other Nova Corps
are going to be dead
this means that Richard Ryder will
inherit the entirety of the Nova force
and although we probably won't see that
happen in real time what is most likely
going to happen is that when the
guardians of the galaxy return to Xander
they will find Richard Reiter there at
this point in time it'll be an
incredibly long time after the
destruction of Xander it will be after
the five year gap so when the Guardians
run into Richard Ryder he's
already going to be Nova he would have
had the Nova force for five years
probably a little more when the
Guardians end up getting to him but when
the guardians of the galaxy go and find
Nova ons and are they might find that
the Society has been re-established
because as it was revealed Marvell plan
to introduce the xandarians world mine
and the xandarians mine actually has the
power to restore the population you see
the Zen darian world mines database
actually has the brains of all the
deceased members of the Nova Corps and
the entire population of xander and in
the comics when all of the population of
xander was destroyed the zen durian
world line actually restored the
population by cloning everybody who once
lived
essentially resurrecting Xander so when
the guardians go to Xander and guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 it may not be
destroyed it may have been restored by
Nova so this is how I think we could see
Nova get introduced into the MCU this is
in no way confirmed this is just my own
opinion of how I think it could happen
based off of everything that we already
know Nova is still a top priority for
Marvel and the MCU according to its
President Kevin Feige and we know that
before the plans were to tie him into
guardians of the galaxy so it would make
sense that we would see him in guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 especially if they
plan on introducing him in another film
before he gets his own solo movie so let
me know your thoughts on this let me
know what you think about this new
information that has been revealed about
this in darian world mine and would you
have liked to have seen nova in infinity
war and avengers endgame or do you think
that he is better off introduced after
the fact let me know what you think in
the comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment with your
favorite superhero or villain so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 as always thank you
all so much for watching we'll fluff